[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday September 30th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
you might remember that last year we
brought you a special three-part series
called The Tick Tock Spyro
a Wall Street Journal investigation
found that tick tock's algorithm was
flooding some teens for you pages with
videos encouraging weight loss and
disordered eating we heard from three of
them
I saw a lot of videos of people saying
what I eat in a day it made me start
thinking maybe I should start purging to
get rid of the weight eventually there
were like some self-harm and suicide a
lot of ideation I would just swipe and
that's it my feet was literally like a
mostly consisting of that the series was
part of an even bigger wsj investigation
that showed tick tock's recommendation
algorithm would funnel users into seeing
videos on a narrow range of topics last
December Tick Tock which is owned by
Chinese parent bite dance said that it
was adjusting the way its algorithm
makes recommendations to avoid overly
focusing on one type of content and two
months later the company expanded an
existing ban on content related to
eating disorders but nine months on from
the wsj investigation there's still
plenty of that harmful content on tick
tock here to discuss why is our family
and Tech columnist Julie jargon hi Julie
thanks for joining us hi thank you for
having me all right you spoke with users
who say they are still seeing eating
disorder content when they're on Tick
Tock what kinds of things did they
describe were coming up on their for you
page
yeah it seems to have changed from being
really blatant videos that are promoting
disordered eating and Extreme Weight
Loss it's become a bit more subtle and
the difficult thing about that according
to mental health experts is that it's
harder for teens to discern what is
healthy diet related videos from
unhealthy and so some examples of that
include a topic of videos that are kind
of broadly Under the Umbrella of what I
eat in a day and oftentimes these videos
will have you know the people in the
video showing what they eat throughout a
day and how much calories they consume
by the end of the day oftentimes the
calorie count is far less than what the
FDA recommends people consume in a day
and so for people who may really need to
lose weight that could potentially be
helpful but to a lot of people that can
be harmful if they're trying to emulate
sort of restricted food intake
throughout the course of a day another
category of content on Tick Tock which
Tick Tock says it allows on its platform
our eating disorder recovery videos and
for some people it can be really helpful
to see the journey that someone has gone
through in their recovery from an eating
disorder but for a lot of teens that
I've spoken to those kind of videos can
end up being kind of harmful and end up
fueling some competition in them various
eating disorder experts say that Eating
Disorders are a very competitive type of
disorder to have and so in some of these
videos people will show photos of
themselves before and after so showing
photos when they were at their thinnest
versus where they are in their recovery
now and so some teens I've spoke to said
that that makes them feel like maybe
they didn't lose as much weight does
that other person did also sometimes
sows doubts in them about whether they
themselves were ever as sick as the
person they're seeing in that video so
Tick Tock says it allows recovery videos
but it has put in place restrictions to
block other harmful content and yet
these videos make it onto the platform
is this just about videos falling into a
gray area when it comes to being harmful
or are there other ways that users are
getting around this it's a bit of both
you know certainly there are some videos
that are more nuanced and might not be
considered a blatant violation of tick
tock's Community guidelines they might
not be pro-eating disorder per se and
could can in fact be helpful and
inspiring to some people who see them
and potentially triggering to others who
see them but then there are ways that
people have found to kind of get around
some of tick tock's filters so for
example
certain obvious eating disorder related
terms have been filtered out on Tick
Tock so if you're searching the word
anorexic in Tick Tock search engine you
won't find videos that contain that
hashtag instead you'll be directed to
messages from the national Eating
Disorders Association but until recently
people could simply do a Google search
and search the hashtag anorexic Tick
Tock and go right to those videos that
contain that hashtag and it might be
more in the realm of pro-eating disorder
content I brought that to tick tock's
attention and they have fixed that but
there are a lot of other workarounds
including misspellings of eating
disorder related terms transposing
letters including numbers different ways
to get around the hashtag filters so has
Tick Tock said anything about the
content still being on its platform what
they said to me was that caring for a
diverse Global Community is a
responsibility they take seriously and
that they're mindful that triggering
content is varied and unique to each
individual
how do mental health and eating disorder
experts say they're dealing with
patients who are you know using social
media and finding themselves in this
position because it just doesn't seem
like it's going away that's right a
mental health experts say that there
probably will never be a completely safe
space online for people who are
struggling with really any kind of
mental health issue and eating disorders
in particular there's just a pervasive
diet culture online to begin with and
offline as well what some mental health
experts have told me is that it's you
know unfortunately Falls to people who
are using social media to try to run
away from this content and to try to
block it themselves you know one mental
health expert said she had a patient who
basically had to retrain her Tick-Tock
algorithm by not only unfollowing diet
related accounts but then following body
positive content creators and liking
their videos to indicate to the
algorithm that she wanted to see that
type of content but again it it's not
perfect and it's also a big ask to
expect someone who's struggling with
something to make a conscious decision
to get away from it alright that was our
family and Tech columnist Julie jargon
Julie thanks so much for joining us
thank you for having me
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our producer is Julie Chang we
had editorial assistance this week from
Ariana oscaru our supervising producer
is Chris Tinsley our executive producer
is Katara Yocum and I'm your host Zoe
Thomas thanks for listening and have a
great weekend
foreign